so the point here is that yes if there
were a country if Jewish people were a
country but not in Palestine it's like
basically I'm coming to your house and I
said you know I'm taking over your house
when he said to me sh when he say about
Shi why you taking over my house I would
say excuse me you don't think I do have
a
house racist you giving me a house no
you tell you deserve a house no doubt
but not in my house you understand so
Jewish people they deserve a country to
be to know where in Germany Germany
should give them a country or Britain
because German they are the one who
tortured them killed them and European
they should give them a country no
coming to Palestine Palestine a country
where people has a country that has been
already established you come and who
gave it to them is the British 1948 B
for B for the the Declaration which took
place in Manchester yes so how you going
to give a country how you going to give
something not belong to you to someone
does not deserve it Jewish people are
welcome to live under the Muslim
countries no doubt but you cannot come
take over a country and if we accept you
say oh you're
racist I tell you why because in Algeria
yes in Morocco no there's a lot of them
in Morocco in Algeria do you know why
because when the French came took over
Algeria Jewish people not all of them
but a lot lot of them side with with
with the French against
algerians that's right not all of them
by the way there are some of them who
stood and guess the the the the the what
they call it the the the Invaders so the
point here is that this argument I
respect here this argument is like
emotional argument is that they don't
deserve a country yeah okay they deserve
a country but not come to our country
take over and if we don't accept if we
fight back against you you could race
terrorist no we're not terrorist we are
fighting for our country you know if the
English people fight against another uh
people yeah for their country they're
not terrorists so it seems like they
there double standard okay and also what
you have to understand I always like
people said as a story of Jewish people
how how they've been they've been
oppressed and we don't we don't negate
that yes theyve but likewise they've
been the oppressors too are you aware
they been oppressors Jewish people well
on that note everyone has been an
oppressor at some point any this this
this argument
large I think do logical fallacy
because you saying basically yeah but my
point say the Jews have been oppressors
I mean okay maybe but they've also been
oppressed
yeah English have been oppressors they'
been oppressed to have been oppress
they've been oppressed too everyone has
been oppressed yeah but why why why my
point here is why we only hear about
Jewish people when they've been
oppressed why no one tell us when they
were oppressors I thought we were
talking about Evolution are you talk
about Evolution
now go to no no no because from your old
book from the old from the Bible not
isamic book from the Jewish book it show
us how many years Jewish people oppress
people but that doesn't mean we should
oppress them don't get me wrong you
understand but my point is we always
when we try to speak about the issue of
Palestine Palestine should have the the
Palestine is belong to the Palestinians
and the Zionist should have no nothing
over Palestine if they want a country go
somewhere else where we here anti salite
we've been oppressed okay why don't want
tell us about your oppression for many
centuries understand but again as a
Muslim Allah teach me to be just doesn't
mean that some Jewish people oppress
other people who should oppress Jewish
people no Jewish people are welcome to
live in Egypt in Algeria in other
countries but you cannot come to my
country take over if I don't accept you
you say you know what you are a bigot
you are racist you are anti-site no I'm
not CU I'm a samite I'm from sh from
Sam I mean the the son of Noah okay so
what you have to say about this about
because you told me do because your
argument was do you not think the Jewish
people deserve State and I have
responded to it what do you think
[Music]
say you know one of the reasons why they
say they belong there because of
scripture well yeah I mean you got
Jerusalem there is basically where
jism as far as I understand it they B
their
justification you're not even
I believe not it's interesting because
most zist don't believe God exist but
they do believe that you know Palestine
that's why there's a lot of Jewish
people and get Zionist are you aware of
that Joe yesare yeah yeah Shmi yeah nice
to meet you Joe thank you very much man
yeah that's why there's many Jewish
people against even they protest I see
them protesting against the the Zionist
they say what they doing is wrong I mean
look if you look to full history Jewish
people lived with the Muslims in in
Palestine for many centuries okay am I
saying no Muslims even never did wrong
to the Jewish people no there were some
rulers who did oppress Jewish people and
that's Haram it's forbidden Islam you
see wh speak the truth you see
alhamdulillah and Islam teach us we
should not oppress no one you understand
but what's happen in Palestine the
Zionist are oppressing the Palestinians
no doubt about it bro they're killing
children and you tell me they're looking
for Hamas even P Morgan you know P
Morgan uh not personally yeah but do you
know is yeah yeah even P sman now he
started not sin you know what we can't
even defend this anymore should been
killed woman been killed innocent
people yeah what do you think about this
solution is that the the zionists should
get out of Palestine and Jewish people
who live been there they should live
they live there should not be moved
because they is their country too but
that country belongs to the
Palestinians that's solution you know
for the Nation about this specific
situation because it's obligation from
The Lord of the
creation okay Joe have a nice you want
to talk maybe to Jal but with me I think
you very very tired I'm all right take
care of you so have a nice weekend thank
you very much we here every Friday Joe
yes thank you oh I see you